[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
débrief des questions au gouvernement du
23 juin à retenir aujourd'hui tout
d'abord cette image celle d'un retour à
la normale ou presque à l'assemblée
nationale puisque tous les députés
peuvent à nouveau siéger
sauf que parlementaires et ministres
doivent porter un masque sauf quand ils
prennent la parole
c'est une règle qui vaut pour tout le
monde y compris pour le premier ministre
illustration avec cet échange qui porte
sur le thème qu'a suscité le plus de
questions aujourd'hui la convention
citoyenne sur le climat question posée
par andré chassaigne le président du
groupe des députés communistes et
républicains qui veut savoir tout
simplement ce que le gouvernement compte
faire des propositions de la convention
citoyenne
écoutez la réponse d'edouard philippe
masqué mais franchement
ces propositions elles ont vocation à
susciter le débat public
elles ont vocation à être discuté
travaillé peut être modifié peut être
adoptée par les seuls représentants
légitimes dans l'ordre démocratique qui
sont susceptibles de voter la loi les
parlementaires assemblée nationale et
sénat et je suis prêt monsieur le
président chassaigne a discuté de
l'ensemble de ces propositions
ici à l'assemblée nationale après que au
cours dans le courant de la semaine
prochaine
le président de la république aura
indiquée
ce qu'il retient de cette expérience et
la façon dont nous pouvons continuer à
avancer jour merci
un autre échange à présent plus
politique celui là il concerne les
déclarations faites par l'ancien
procureur financière devant la
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
l'indépendance de la justice à cette
occasion eliane houlette a évoqué les
pressions qu'elle aurait subi de sa
hiérarchie
dans le cadre de la sphère fillon en
2012 et du coup le député les
républicains julien aubert a voulu en
savoir plus il a posé la question à
nicole belloubet la garde des sceaux
outre des demandes de transmission
rapide d'actes procéduraux sur l'enquêté
concernant françois fillon madame
houlette a fait état d'une convocation
par madame le procureur général de paris
catherine champrenault
pour que l' enquête préliminaire
déclenchée le 25 janvier 2017 laisse la
place à une information judiciaire
permettant la désignation d'un juge
d'instruction
madame houlette a fini par obtempérer et
monsieur serge tournaire a été désigné
madame champrenault évoque dans son
communiqué un courrier en date du 17
février 2010 être clamant louguet
réclamant l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire
mais ce courrier est introuvable ceci
viole l'article 36 du code de procédure
pénale qui prévoit que les instructions
écrites procédurales sont versés au
dossier
comment l'expliquez vous les propos de
l'ancien procureur républicain
financière devant la commission denquête
de votre assemblée nationale on a tort
ou à raison distiller le doute sur
l'indépendance et l'impartialité
invité de la justice dans la conduite de
la faire vous évoquez je sais que votre
commission d' enquête présidée par
monsieur bernalicis procédera à toutes
les auditions nécessaires pour que les
réponses aux interrogations qui se
posent soit formulée je le dis et je le
répète devant vous nous pouvons donner
des instructions générales mais nous ne
pouvons pas donné d'instructions je
parle de la garde des sceaux
d'instructions particulières dans des
affaires particulières c'est tout à fait
essentiel voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un autre débrief des
questions au gouvernement
[Musique]